2,50 les plus gros là ils savent déjà
qu'on est là il nous ont déjà ressenti
les vibrations qu'on fait dans
l'eau du coup on va y aller doucement
pour qu'il
s'habitue tu fais du bruit à la surface
ça va venir voir ce que c'est c'est
vraiment un poisson incroyable des fois
les gros gros tuar à les pendre dans les
bras ils veulent
bien c'est sympa les gens il doivent te
prendre pour un fou non certain ou il en
a ou
ouis salut moi c'est Florient
journaliste pour BR spécialis dans
l'environnement et la nature et
aujourd'hui on est avec Pierre alenilet
l'homme qui nage avec les silurs on est
parti c'est parti VO là on va essayer de
de se mettre à l'eau et d'aller voir
dans les arbes immerger si on peut aller
voir les
silures c'est un gros poisson chat il
peut atteindre des grosses tailles
jusqu'à 3
m c'est un poisson qui qui est carnivore
et qui mange un peu tout très
opportuniste je les
cherche chef des quo
les
[Musique]
é
je ça fait combien de tu fais ça 25 ans
que je fais
ça assez
régulièrement même des fois tous les j
tous les jours partout où il y a de
l'eau je plonge partout il y a de la
faune il y a des choses à voir je plonge
en fait au début moi je suis un pêcheur
de carpe et puis de pêcheur je suis
devenu plongeur intéressant ce qu'on ne
voit pas de la surface du coup GAM j'ai
commencé à plonger puis c'est devenu
comme ça une vraie
passion passion sportive et puis
toujours de la
découverte to tu peux rester sous l'
ouais 5 minutes quand je viens
d'entraîner avec le courant comme ça
c'est c'est assez fatiguant des fois je
reste 5 6 he avec eux quand les
conditions sont vraiment
optimales il sont là là sous l'arbre là
il y a des figures j'ai vu la queue on
va aller voir de près on va approcher
tout doucement et puis on va aller les
filmer c'est pas du tout dangereux pour
l'homme ça peut ordre ça peut arriver
mais c'est pas c'est pas
dangereux il a plein de gens qui
racontent des légendes sur les figures
comme quoi ça peut manger des humains et
cetera les humains non parce qu'on est
très gros mais par contre un petit chien
ça oui ça il y a possibilité c'est quoi
le régime alimentaire d' sil tout ce qui
peut trouver à proximité de l'eau et
dans l'eau les écrevices les poissons à
l'intérieur de l'eau les coquillages les
molusques et puis aussi tous les animaux
qu'il y a à térieur de l'eau les canards
les martres les fouines les ragondins
tous les animaux qui vient de l'eau les
oiseaux
après pant qu'il mange un pigeon il
mange pas les poissons en fait ainsi de
suite en
fait là tu rentres doucement et tu vas
voir
il tu vas
doucement
[Musique]
ça c'est énorme il est plus grand que
moi tu l'as pas vu cel qui passe dans
tes pieds je l'ai pas vu il entre tes
palmes il mesure combien les ure là le
plus gros qu'on a vu là
2,50 2,40
2,50 il y en avait un qui faisait
presque 2,80 il a 450 ça et ce silure on
le voit plus il a disparu soit il a été
pêché ou soit il est mort de de mort
naturelle mais il a disparu ce gros
silure
je vois plus je le vois
plus il est toujours là mais je vois
plus les gros gros on les reconnait en
plus parce que chacun a une morphologie
bien bien distinct et du coup il
s'habitue et puis là oui on arrive
vraiment vraiment à les caresser à
pouvoir les prendre dans les bras ils
acceptent bien ouais sans leur faire
peur sans les stresser mais bon après ça
c'est il faut passer beaucoup de temps
tu penses qu'il te reconnaissent au fur
à mesure et cetera bah ils me
reconnaissent pas moi en tant
qu'individu mais ils reconnaissent le
plongeur ils savent que bah il y a aucun
danger on va voir un peu plus haut il
est temps mais j'ai encore vu mais c'est
pas
[Musique]
filmable
and
remé qu'on fait B Bou dans l'eau
l' de dire pour passionn pour
Lesur c'est un poisson tellement
intelligent quand il
chasse quand il se déplace quand quand
on va à côté de lui des fois il vient
vous voir il a une proximité avec
l'homme qui peut se faire qui est très
agréable et puis il faut quand même 3 m
de long c'est quand même assez
impressionnant un qui vit en groupe
rarement seul quand il y en a il y en a
beaucoup et quand il y en a pas il y en
a pas du tout en fait c'est pour ça
qu'on a l'impression qu'on qui par zone
qui sont beaucoup beaucoup
mais en fait c'est que ils sont dans une
zone et puis il peut y avoir 2 km sans
plus un silure en
fait il aura plus après
plus c'est pas du tout un poisson qui
est menacé puisquil est en pleine
expansion dans l'Europe maintenant on en
trouve partout dans tous les pays
européens pratiquement après il y a un
problème sur les faunes qui sont pas
habitué à ce poisson parce qu'il prend
ça il prend la niche écologique de
certains autres prédateurs comme le
brocher le cendre et du coup on a quand
même des populations de brochet de
cendre qui s'effondent mais je dirais
pas que c'est à cause du silure la plus
grosse cause je pense que c'est la
pollution qui est quand même surtout nos
rivières et nos fleuves assez présente
quand même donc aujourd'hui la
population elle est quand même
relativement stabilisée c'est plus
vraiment un problème ouais dans la Loire
elle est stabilisée ça c'est sûr il y a
moins d'individus il y a des plus gros
individus mais en ont beaucoup moins
qu'il y a 15 20
ans